with an assist tonight he'll
look to put his team up on
the first opportunity of this shootout Suzuki
scores just weaved into the Zone here
coming across at his forehand side just
a quick release pick that low Corner
Chris leang get through his career on
it shootout attempts 26 of 80 in the career
of Chris leang the Montreal kid in on mono
scores now he's still got
it what a j beautiful just same
kind of approach of Suzuki he dips
a shoulder gives him a Shimmy Shake
and then elevates it h over the glove
Cofield with five goals in 13 shootout
attempts the serpentine route Coffield
scores he just kind of weaved in and much
the same as latangi got a little tighten
and just far down so now Sydney Crosby will
look to answer for the Penguins got 42 goals
in the shootout and 109 attempts two goals
on the night Crosby twisting and turning
scores there is no stick hotter in the Penguins
lineup right now than that guy magic and Montreal
for Crosby and he's weaving in two looked like
he was going to run out of space and then bang
he strikes here here comes yesi oenin the delovic
trying to keep this shooter off the board and it
hits the [Applause] post so now the Penguins
Ned gives his post a little tap thank you the
first save in the shootout Ned's post Jake gensel
can walk it off and win it in front of the dads
Kel goes wide a
fired goals back and forth taking turns post
at one end and gel the game on his stick
measures so now your I slav kovski
the chance to put Montreal back in
front slavkovsky with speed stopped by
NAD [Applause] delovic he was a hero a
few nights ago in Buffalo scoring the winner
in a shootout in the same shooting position
here tonight Stoned by Ned and gny Malin
he can win it for Pittsburgh Malin save
montmo montmo just got
that as Gino was looking to end it here
he looked like he was out of space that
little flick back through the five hole
able to stay with it as montol squeeze
it yel armia one for five in his career in
the shootout he comes in missed the net and
again a chance here for the Penguins to win the
game and it's Lester's son Riley Smith over the
boards and on the ice before his dad goes
to the other dad's trip yeah send him away
happy you're watching the driveway Subaru of Moon
Township shootout out Riley Smith can win it save
monmo fans come to their feet here this thing
is [Applause] [Music] going deep as Riley Smith
to try to pick five hole there it was shut
down Christian dorak 6 for 13 pretty good
in these shootout situations and on ad delovic
missed the net and crashed into to doovic in the
process oh boy alex the delovic slow
to get up Chris Stewart Penguins out
athletic trainer coming over to 10 to the
goal tender we'll get another look at this
hopefully they went to that glove side again on
Ned and he's been throwing that glove out pretty
good just a fake shot to the back hand and then
is he kicked in the head it looked like he had a
little contact up high there you're watching the
D driveway Subaru of Moon Township shootout the
doovic nervously smiling is his dad he's okay
he's okay he's okay I seen him do this when he
was 12 so here we go again this time it's Eric
Carlson for the win Carlson's bomb is stopped by
monmo righty coming down kind of
delayed in the slot he's looking
just to turn that blade over and elevated
it up under the far over the glove get
him to drop Sean Monahan 18 of 49 in his
career in the shootout he comes in shot
score back to that glove
side he came in from his offside and
put it back through the glove side on
Movic so Lars Eller a goal keeps it going a
save from montmo wins it for Montreal Eller
scores what a move and top shelf
the ex Canadian there seemed to
be a little extra juice when he was going
game on the line and what a move by Lars
L at the to keep it going awesome
this is awesome Mike Mat going go
now for Montreal the former penguin Here
Comes mat M delovic with the stick says
no oh baby Jeff Carter is coming on the
ice we're in round eight he's turned back
the clock over the last 24 hours here
he comes for the win butter stopped by
montmo round nine Carter just tried to come
in with speed little back and for and and
beat montmo to that post and he couldn't
Michael pizetta going for Montreal he'll
take a wide route petta stopped by natovich
that was only his third never attempt in
the shootout he had scored once previously
there just a wide route in on his forehead
here just tried to blast it [Applause]
through Val ter poon and has never scored
an NHL goal but he'll take a shootout
goal cuz he'd win it and he missed the
net came in trying to open up on that off side
weaving across Le that stick open
and just missing the net low Walker
side we're going on first ever shootout
attempt here's Evans slows up movich
stopped [Applause] him people can't believe
what they're seeing the dads are going oh here
we go we can do it here we're in the 10th
round this is the longest shootout of this
regular season so far in the National
hockey league has redeemed zahna seen
enough
zahna save monm B trying to bait him bait
monteo he's keeping it on that side of the
net and then quickly over to the forehand
with that big reach Brendan Gallagher yet
to go for Montreal that changes right
now two for 10 in his career in the
shootout Gallagher n delovic
again with a stop these goalies
are dialed they're dialed are their post oh my
goodness everyone everyone was on their feet
there make a memory Vinnie hza juggles the puck
and he comes henrosa St stop by monmo he ran out
of real estate and montmo just stayed right with
him see him here just slowing down unable
to beat montmo and Josh Anderson will go
for Montreal one for two in his career in the
shootout Anderson head fake NAD delovic gets a
piece I know he can shoot the Puck he's
got a heavy shot when he's slowed down
around the hash marks right here
I thought yeah he's going to fire
it Ned read him right Jansen Harkins after
this marathon of a shootout can walk it off
scores happy dads and a shootout winner for Jon
Hawkins and the penguins are winners in Montreal
it took forever for that puck to go in it
[Applause] seemed the dads are hugging it
out they're all buddies now oh my goodness
Ned's dad was put through the riger was he
get that man a beer he was hurt he was
up his posts helped him but man was he
good tonight Al NAD delovic and Jansen Harkin
with Just 4 minutes and 24 seconds of ice time
tonight gets the job done here in the
shootout amazing game fans can't believe
it we can't believe it as Harkins comes
in and just found a hole found a hole in
the blocker side and we get the reaction and
the good times keep rolling on this D strip